we see the struggle of others unfold
around us as they fight for the things
important to them there's a man who
fights on behalf of his broken homeland
another who fights to prevent his
kingdom being broken one man believes in
research for the sake of knowledge and
maybe this knowledge will give you the
power to fix your mistake with this
power you may have to do terrible things
to many to save the lives of many more
how can the gods be so cruel to stand
idly by while the powers have everything
taken from them
perhaps if you give them something then
they'll give you something in return
surely there's a reward for faithfully
serving the gods of this land or perhaps
you'll be cast aside to fade from memory
a fool who dared to believe in something
greater without ever knowing that your
final acts could have changed fate
man is born from the dark a soul that is
kindled flickers dwindles and dies in
the shadow of his gods
the human form is fragile and death
comes quickly but the spirit is strong
and it clings to life like only a mortal
can so in a way man was not designed to
become Undead fear of death is what lets
us live take that away and humanity
becomes harder to hold on to without
humanity you could become more hollow
than man yet an undead who would die for
something has nothing to fear for death
simply becomes a stepping stone to his
goal if you fall down seven times
stand up eight that's the cry of the
undead it's not a matter of life or
death it's about what breaks first your
will or the barriers in your way
everyone has their own paths to face
have you seen my father
you wouldn't make him a suit of armor
just like mine
friend I have an idea a good one
really I will rush those dire fiends and
you can slip away in the confusion why
why after all this searching
I still cannot find it was it all a lie
have I done this all for nothing
all of you forgive me five failed
nothing I'm finished we're both on the
brink you see end of story
bloody fool regrettably I have failed in
my mission but perhaps you can keep the
torch lit there is an old saying in my
family thou who art undead art chosen in
nine exodus from the undead asylum
maketh pilgrimage to the land of ancient
Lords when thou ringeth the bell of
awakening the fate of the undead thou
shalt not well now you know and I can
die with hope in my heart so do we fight
for one man who fell no we fight for the
many who fell before us but the souls of
nameless soldiers warriors and heroes
did you ring the second Bell that is
incredible I must say I cannot do it
myself I lack the strength
and the bravery but you finally because
if you're dead will be lifted die and I
assume she's saved school please